with me now Simon Basel jet he's chief
executive of the jockey club Simon great
to see so what's driven this group is it
more race goers all existing race
groovers go with spending more money
race cars are at a record high
maintained from last year but equally
hospitality so better offer a better mix
of offers but media media revenues have
continued to grow strongly and our
commercial partnerships where we people
now increasingly want to be involved
with racing in a way that perhaps 10 or
15 years they didn't and you're saying
companies like Bentley's and boodles and
companies like that getting involved in
the sport but these are new commercial
partners these largely domestic are they
from overseas as well they're mostly
domestic at the moment we have a whole
range of things obviously traditionally
you would expect to see gaming companies
involved we also have a number of
overseas sovereign wealth funds and
royal families involved but increasingly
you know commercial commercial companies
food and drink companies cars those kind
of things are we're seeing growth there
we have invested as the sponsor of the
Derby for example R and X brand ox
health for entry for the Grand Nationals
so it's a range of different companies
so you say that so there's more interest
among commercial partners that there
wasn't maybe a decade ago what is that
is that because you've had to work
harder to get them in or is it just the
quality of the sport is better and it's
become more attractive I think I think
it's both I think we've I think we've
had to raise our game as as every sport
and every business has had to do we've
had to accept that you know we need to
give people a really top class
experience you can't just expect people
to come and know what racing is about
and know what the day is we really have
to make sure that they enjoy it explain
it to them engage them in the sport but
also I'd say the quality of the
experience is is really top class at
racing and the jockey club courses and
the quality of the food and drink that
and catering that's being offered is is
I think a match for anything that's out
there so the big news food is all the
big development is gonna be that the
tote loses its exclusive full betting
license on your race courses and these
will revert back to the industry what
what's that gonna mean for punters what
will the difference be for them well
it's very important of the things that
we've grown over the over the last years
is taking control of things on our
course and where we can really improving
the experience the the the tote which is
the moment these the exclusive
pool betting company on horse racing
there's only one allowed
at the moment that the exclusive license
expires in July it was originally set up
for for the good of racing to put
everything back into racing but it was
sold off by the government to a
bookmaker seven or eight years ago and
this is now our opportunity with the end
of that exclusive license to really take
control of that and offer new new kinds
of products market it better interesting
bets that perhaps you can't do at the
moment and also to make sure that the
customer experience that people get on
course is absolutely top-class and that
allows us to put more money back into
the sport which is what the jockey club
is all about does that mean if I'm going
to say Cheltenham Racecourse that the
totes stands will no longer be there
there'll be Brit bet it's Brit Bet
stands but they look very different
we're going to have much more modern
screens much more information better
trained staff and will be and and it
much more fun bet that you can have you
know perhaps first instead of just the
window or the first two perhaps the
first four of the first five and those
start to add up to to perhaps some
meaningful amounts of money more like a
lottery bets really so that's so new
kinds of things that we think will get a
wider range of people involved in the
sport okay well the other thing that's
going on in the industry right now the
government's consulting on reducing the
maximum stake on fixed or betting
terminals in bookmakers I mean that in
turn could hit the racing industry
revenues can this it could I mean the
government is going through a
consultation process at moment and we'll
wait to see what that does but if the if
the net impact of that is there's less
shops we have a number of revenue
streams where we sell media rights in
particular to shops and on a per short
basis if there are less shops will
clearly have less less revenues and
that's something that that would be a
challenge so we're keeping a closer eye
on that and preparing see what that
would look like but the key thing is all
their other revenue streams are growing
will will be getting into the betting
market ourselves with Brit bet and so
we're confident that we'll be able to
have a robust and resilient business and
we'll continue offering a fantastic
service to our customers well this
weekend we've got the first classic of
the season the two thousand in two
thousand Guineas what's your what's your
fantasy I think it's a bit early to pick
at the moment but that but I will keep
an eye on not in the two thousand years
been in thousand Guineas there's a horse
there a filly called Dan's dream which
is owned by Sir Ian Botham and sir
Gareth Edwards but it's being run for
charity so if it if it for spinal
injuries so if it wins on some day that
will be three hundred and fifteen
thousand pounds for charity that's oh
I'd keep an eye out for that one